we're heading into a very dangerous
phase of history human beings being
addicted to growth are constantly
looking for sources so when we feel
austerity coming on we tend to become
more tribal unfortunately a perfectly
free market will not allow benevolent
firms to survive in the long run my
argument is not an argument for centrism
I regard utopianism as probably the
worst idea that human beings have ever
had we find ourselves unfortunately
stuck in an archaic argument about
policy frankly the left and right are
both out of answers and they should team
up on the basis that they agree at a
values level about what a functional
society should ideally look like
[Music]
human beings like all creatures are the
product of adaptive evolution but they
are highly unusual amongst evolved
creatures in order to understand them it
is very important to recognize certain
things that make us different from even
the most similar creatures like
chimpanzees the most important
difference is something I call the Omega
principle the Omega principle specifies
the relationship between human culture
and the human genome the most important
thing to realize about human beings is
that a tremendous amount of what we are
is not housed in our genomes it's housed
in a cultural layer that is passed on
outside of genes culture is vastly more
flexible more plastic and more more
quickly evolving in an adaptive sense
than genes which is why in fact cultural
evolution came about in human beings it
allows human beings to switch what they
are doing and how they are doing it much
more quickly than they could if all
information that was adapting was stored
in DNA one of the very important
benefits of understanding this
relationship between the genome and the
cultural attributes of human beings is
that it frees us to engage in an
analysis of the evolutionary meaning of
behaviors without having to know where
exactly the information is stored this
is especially important with complex
phenomenon which may be partially housed
in the genome and partially housed in
the cultural layer something like human
language for example human language as a
capacity is obviously genetically
encoded but individual human languages
are not and so if we are to talk about
the adaptive utility of human language
being obligated to specify what is
housed where could put off that
discussion for generations
whereas if we recognize that the
cultural aspects of language as well as
the genomic aspects of language are all
serving a United interest
we can begin to understand the meaning
of something like language in rigorous
adaptive terms the hypothesis of
cultural evolution which is now been
sufficiently tested to be regarded as
the theory of human cultural evolution
is the invention of Richard Dawkins who
in 1976 in The Selfish Gene coined the
term meme as an analogue for gene at a
unit of cultural evolution the genome
creates a brain that is capable of being
infused with culture after an individual
person is born if culture was evolving
to do things that were not in the
genomes interest they would effectively
be wasting the time and resources that
the genetic individual has access to on
frivolous things at best so the genome
would shut down frivolous culture were
it a very common commodity so the theory
of memes tells us that there is a
process very much like the one that
shapes our genomes at work in the
cultural layer that does not mean
however that the cultural evolving layer
is free of obligation to the genome in
fact the cultural layer is downstream
and one of the things that we have
repeatedly gotten wrong as we have
attempted to just simply extend the
rules of adaptive evolution as we have
learned them from other creatures and
apply them to human beings and it leads
to some unfortunate misunderstanding the
fact that we are primarily culturally
informed tells us that culture serves
the genetic interests almost all of the
time which is to say if you look at a
long-standing cultural trait it doesn't
matter what it is whether it's music or
religion or humor all of those things
must be paying for themselves in terms
of genetic fitness once we've recognized
that we can skip to the much more
interesting question of in what way do
some of the
remarkable cultural structures that we
see serve genetic interest some of them
seem absolutely paradoxical if we try to
imagine that they are serving our
genomes and yet that is the conclusion
that we have to reach when we realize
that the genome is not only tolerating
the existence of that culture but it is
facilitating its acquisition this
suggests a very odd state of affairs for
human beings in which we have minds that
are programmed by culture that can be
completely at odds with our genomes and
it leads to misunderstandings of
evolution like the idea that religious
belief is a mind virus that effectively
these belief structures are parasitizing
human beings and they are wasting the
time and effort that those human beings
are spending on that endeavor rather
than the more reasonable interpretation
which is that these belief systems have
flourished because they have facilitated
the interests of the creatures involved
our belief systems are built around
evolutionary success and they certainly
contain human benevolence which is
appropriate to phases of history when
there is abundance and people can afford
to be good to each other the problem is
if you have grown up in a period in
which abundance has been the standard
state you don't anticipate the way
people change in the face of austerity
and so what we are currently seeing is
messages that we have all agreed are
unacceptable re-emerging because the
signals that we have reached the end of
the boom times those signals are
everywhere and so people are triggered
to move into a phase that they don't
even know that they have despite the
fact that human beings think that they
have escaped the evolutionary paradigm
they've done nothing at the time and so
we should expect the belief systems that
people hold to mirror the evolutionary
interest that people have rather
to match our our best instincts when we
are capable of being good to each other
because there's abundance we have those
instincts and so it's not incorrect to
say that human beings are capable of
being marvelous creatures and being
quite ethical and I would argue there's
a simple way of reconciling the correct
understanding that religious belief
often describes truths that in many
cases fly in the face of what we can
understand scientifically with the idea
that these beliefs are adaptive I call
it the state of being literally false
and metaphorically true a belief is
literally false and metaphorically true
if it is not factual
but if behaving as if it were factual
results in an enhancement of one's
fitness to take an example if one
behaves in let's say the Christian
tradition in such a way as to gain
access to heaven one will not actually
find themselves at the pearly gates
being welcomed in but one does tend to
place their descendants in a good
position with respect to the community
that those descendants continue to live
in so if we were to think evolutionarily
the person who is behaving so as to get
into heaven has genetic interests those
genetic interests are represented in the
narrow sense by their immediate
descendants and close relatives in the
larger sense they may be represented by
the entire population of people from
whom that individual came and by acting
so as to get into heaven the fitness of
that person the number of copies of
those genes that continued to flourish
in the aftermath of that person's death
will go up so the belief in heaven is
literally false there is no such place
but it is metaphorically true in the
sense that it results in an increase in
fitness
if you think about all of the things
that you know human beings to have done
over the course of human history you'll
realize that humans must have shifted
from one niche to the other again and
again effectively humans are a niche
switching creature that is the human
niches to discover new things to do when
the ancestral waves have petered out and
are no longer useful innovating new ways
to be is very much the human toolkit
when human beings adopt an opportunity
their population grows in proportion to
the size of that opportunity and that
opportunity essentially should be
thought of as a frontier now there are
many kinds of frontiers that human
humans have discovered the most obvious
kind of frontier is a geographic
frontier when a population discovers an
uninhabited island or in an extreme case
they discover a continent that has no
people on it that is a tremendous
opportunity in a tiny population can
grow to gigantic size given such a bit
of good fortune but there are less
obvious kinds of frontier as well
technological frontier occurs when
people discover a mechanism for doing
more with the territory that they have
so for example if you think about a
piece of territory that has been
inhabited by hunter-gatherers at the
point that farming is either invented or
brought in discovered by some other
population that same piece of territory
if it is hospitable to farming can
support a much larger population so it
functions just like having discovered a
new land mass because the size of the
population that exists on the current
landmass goes up as a result of the fact
that the the land is made more
productive there's a third kind of
frontier which I call a transfer
frontier which is not really the same in
the sense that it is zero-sum somebody
has to lose in order for somebody else
to win but from the point of view of an
individual population a population that
cannot defend the resources that it has
is an opportunity and so many of the
worst chapters in human history involve
a population targeting another
population that can't defend the
resources that it owns and so for the
population doing the targeting capturing
those resources functions like having
discovered a new land mass or a new
technology that allows productivity to
go up all of these types of frontier
eventually run out there is simply a
limit to the number of geographical
locations that can be inhabited there
may always be a next technology but the
discovery of new technologies comes in
fits and starts and there can be long
drive periods where you have exceeded
reached or exceeded the limits of a
technological opportunity and the next
one is nowhere on the horizon so human
beings being addicted to growth are
constantly looking for sources and when
Geographic frontiers and technological
frontiers don't provide those
opportunities human beings will
sometimes look within their own
population and figure out who can't
defend the resources that they hold and
they manufacture reasons that they are
not entitled to keep them and so when we
feel austerity coming on we tend to
become more tribal and this is a very
dangerous pattern of history for example
what took place during the Holocaust
when German population decided to target
European Jews and it made up reasons
that those Jews were not entitled to
continue so what we are effectively
seeing in the present is a circumstance
in which we have reached the end of a
boom and human beings are becoming
tribal because that is that is the
natural transition at the end of a
growth period and we are naturally
inspired to look for something to
replace the growth that has run out this
is why many of these abhorrent messages
have become resonant in the present too
many people they're waiting to hear
somebody explain what population is
incapable of defending its resources and
to explain what just of
ocation will be used to pursue those
resources and to transfer them many
people are optimistic that technological
breakthroughs will continue to provide
access to growth this is an unfortunate
perspective because it leads us into a
false sense of security not realizing
that being evolutionary creatures we are
not programmed to preserve that state of
growth and make it last a long time what
we are wired to do is to capture the
benefits of them and bring them into use
what that means for most creatures is
when a nonzero-sum opportunity has been
discovered creatures create many more
like themselves basically more mouths to
feed for modern people sometimes
creating more mouths is not the natural
reaction but creating greater
consumption is and so as much as we are
wired in a way that's beneficial where
we discover new ways of doing more with
less that provides abundance we are also
wired to use up that abundance in
consumption and in fact we have a
dynamic in which are our economic
theories the ones that we run society on
the basis of actually define economic
health that growth is the conversion of
useful energy into useless heat and the
conversion of useful materials into
useless waste so we have what I call a
throughput society where we view
ourselves as doing something right as we
are taking resources that might be made
to last a long time and we use them up
so for example if I were to invent a
microwave oven that is just as useful as
the one you have but would last 10 times
as long as the one you have intuitively
it seems that that should be a very good
thing but from the point of view of the
economy it will result in a reduction in
growth because fewer microwave ovens
will be sold so by defining our economic
terms such that they lead us to correct
for
our improvements in efficiency and cause
us to capture resources and use them up
in one kind of consumption or another we
set ourselves up for a situation in
which no matter how good an opportunity
we discover it is inherently temporary
ethics evolved to limit the
self-destructive behavior internal to a
population unfortunately in our present
circumstance where we have we have
handed over so many functions to an
anonymous marketplace people that learn
where the ethical landscape that we
describe to ourselves where on that
landscape there are opportunities that
are unpleased actually come out ahead
if you discover things that are
unethical that therefore many people
will not engage in but you're willing to
engage in those things and there's no
penalty either informal or legal built
into the system then you will come out
ahead as a result of your increased
freedom because you're not ethically
limited to the narrower set of
acceptable behaviors and so
unfortunately society has begun
rewarding people who are good at
figuring out where we are not policing
our ethical standards and exploiting
those opportunities as a competitive
advantage
the fate of benevolent firms in the
market is a very important topic
unfortunately a perfectly free market
will not allow benevolent firms to
survive in the long run and that may
seem like an overly declarative
statement but the problem is this if you
imagine two firms one of which is
perfectly amoral and will do absolutely
anything that generates a profit and the
other one which is constrained by
ethical beliefs that prevent it from
availing itself of certain economic
opportunities then it doesn't matter
what the economic circumstance is the
amoral corporation or firm always has an
advantage
the best that can be true is that the
ethical choice is also the strategically
best choice and the two will be dead
even but in any case where there's any
distinction whatsoever between the
ethical choice and the perfectly a moral
choice the a moral firm has the
advantage of being perfectly free to
avail itself of opportunities that its
competitor cannot reach and what this
does is it causes evolution of firms to
in the direction of ruthlessness it is
oftentimes the case that people who set
things in motion in the marketplace with
the best of intentions are surprised at
what ultimately becomes of their
innovations Google famously began with
the prime directive
don't be evil and many people have
recognized that over time Google has
become more ruthless than it was at the
start this is actually a perfectly
predictable phenomenon the reason that
Google was able to have noble objectives
at first was that it existed in an
immature market we're having ethical
restraints on what is possible did not
put it at a competitive disadvantage to
any viable competitor that it faced as a
market matures its tolerance for firms
that restrain themselves is much reduced
and a perfectly efficient market has
effectively no tolerance for
self-restraint as a result of this firms
evolve to become more ruthless or they
perish and either way what we find is an
increased tendency in a market as it
becomes more efficient towards
ruthlessness this does not have to be
the case but it is the result of the
fact that we leave the market free for
this kind of evolutionary trajectory if
we were wise about this we would realize
that a free market is not the ideal
state we don't want to tinker we don't
want to meddle in a way that is overly
disruptive of innovation but we do want
to tinker enough that the evolutionary
tendency produces the kind
affirms that we wish to see rather than
ones that behave in a way that horror
focuses we find ourselves unfortunately
stuck in an archaic argument about
policy we're right and left disagree
about the wisdom of tinkering with
society to make certain things better in
general the left is overly enthusiastic
about meddling and it doesn't appreciate
the full danger of unintended
consequences and the right is overly
skeptical of the advantages of tinkering
and prone to focus on the unintended
consequences and be under ambitious with
respect to making society better but the
entire argument is based on ideas of the
18th and 19th century and those ideas
are simply not up-to-date enough to deal
with the problems of the 21st century so
my argument would be that those on the
left and right who are in favor of
Liberty as perhaps the highest human
value should put aside their policy
differences because frankly the left and
right are both out of answers and they
should team up on the basis that they
agree at a values level about what a
functional society should ideally look
like and we should actually begin a new
conversation about policy in which we
investigate what we can do that the
founders of this nation and others that
are modelled on it couldn't imagine
because they didn't have the tools at
their disposal in particular we should
be very careful that whatever solution
making we engage in is evolutionarily
aware the founders of the United States
did not of course know anything about
evolution those who have constructed our
markets did not know anything about
evolution and what they have done
repeatedly is accidentally set up an
evolutionary system in which adaptation
begins to take place without anybody's
awareness and what that tends to do is
it tends to take
the best intentions of those who set up
these systems and overrun them with
things that simply function it results
in dangerous patterns like regulatory
capture where those entities that figure
out how to tinker those parts of the
governance apparatus that are supposed
to regulate them come out ahead of those
that don't attempt to tinker with those
elements my argument is not an argument
for centrism I believe that the answers
that we are looking for are not actually
on the map of possibilities that we are
familiar with we are effectively living
in flatland and what we have to do is
learn to detect the z-axis so that we
can seek solutions of a type that will
at first be unfamiliar to us there's a
great danger in doing this of course
which is utopianism I regard utopianism
as probably the worst idea that human
beings have ever had and if anyone
doubts that that's the case you should
look at the history of utopian ideas
across the 20th century the untold
number of bodies that stacked up as a
result of utopian ideas run amok is
absolutely staggering utopians make two
errors the first error is they
prioritize a single value now because of
the way mechanisms function any time you
optimize a single value you create
incredibly large costs for every other
value in question by you by prioritizing
things like liberty or equality if you
do so in a narrowly focused way you
can't help but generate a dystopian
result because all of the other values
that people might hold are effectively
destroyed in the process the other
mistake that utopians make is they tend
to imagine that they know what the
future state should look like and they
miss what every inventor knows which is
that your grandest ideas are crude to
begin with you have to build a prototype
in order to
figure out what you don't understand and
so I would argue we cannot describe the
future that we should be seeking we can
say what direction it probably is in and
we can head in that direction
intelligently but the minute we start
telling ourselves that we know what the
state that we are trying to construct
looks like we will suffer the same
failure that an inventor that wanted to
bypass the prototyping stage would
suffer there are two kinds of conflict
that people can find themselves in they
can be in conflict when they have
fundamentally different interests from
each other but very frequently for human
beings we will find ourselves in
conflict with somebody with whom we are
aligned but we have a difference of
opinion about what to pursue or in what
manner to do so and there are a couple
of things that evolution can tell us
about how to address such a conflict to
be productive the first thing is it is
very important to figure out what it is
that causes you to disagree sometimes
you may be disagreeing over values so
for example if two people prioritize
things differently they may have a
different sense about what should be
done on the other hand people may be
disagreeing about how to accomplish
something while being completely aligned
with respect to what it is that is
desired so establishing what it is that
has you disagreeing is very important
I'll give you an example I frequently
find as somebody who comes from the
political left that I have very easy
conversations with libertarians on the
right and those conversations remain
easy until we get to the question of
policy at the point we get to the
question of policy we diverge and the
reason that we diverge is actually that
we have different expectations about the
danger of creating new policy but we do
not disagree over the values a
right-of-center economic libertarian
will agree that ideally the market works
best when opportunity is as broadly
distributed as possible so that
everybody has
an opportunity to innovate they may
disagree about how equal the opportunity
is currently and they may also disagree
about the wisdom of attempting to
redistribute opportunity so that people
who don't have it can gain access to it
but there's no disagreement over whether
it is a desirable characteristic on the
other hand there may be disagreements
over what objectives are worthy of
pursuing that some people would like to
see Liberty prioritized over equality
for example and some other group of
people may want to see equality promoted
at a cost to Liberty those are both
valid perspectives and it is worth
understanding that when values are at
issue there may actually be no
resolution to reasonable people can
disagree over how valuable various
objectives are and when that's the case
simply recognizing that the difference
cannot be resolved at the level of
discovering that somebody is correct and
somebody is incorrect because in but in
fact both positions are equally valid I
would say that there's a failure in the
way we view argument that in general I
think our politicized and polarized
atmosphere has caused us to look at
arguments as always tactical and one
thing that you find when you interact
with people who are very adept
intellectually is that they are often
capable of putting aside suspicions
about the motives of the people with
whom they are arguing and they will
argue not to win but to discover what is
true and it's a very different state of
affairs because although nobody likes
being shown to be wrong the great thing
about being shown to be wrong is that it
gives you the opportunity to correct
your understanding and to be wiser the
next time you encounter the question
rather than entrenching yourself in a
wrong position and suffering the costs
of being wrong every time you encounter
the question so putting aside a desire
to win
and substituting a desire to discover
what is true is the key to discovering
truth through argument which benefits
everybody who participates those who
have turned out to be correct those who
have turned out to be incorrect and in
general what typically happens is one
will discover that nobody was perfectly
correct and then all sides have
increased their understanding based on
hashing out the the details of what they
disagree over we're heading into a very
dangerous phase of history where a large
number of people especially young people
have become convinced that the free
exchange of ideas is not only no longer
necessary but is actually
counterproductive and so they set out to
silence those who have opinions at odds
with theirs
some of the people who have opinions at
odds with theirs truly believe abhorrent
things but the problem is until you
fully understand a topic you don't know
which opinions to shut out one has to
actually engage beliefs that are at odds
with your own beliefs in order to figure
out whether what you believe is correct
and to improve it where it isn't correct
so shutting down speech is has become
the mode for a large number of
individuals who believe they see very
clearly what is wrong with civilization
and what must be done to improve it and
they are unfortunately shutting down
people who have vital things to tell
them that they definitely need to know
[Music]
the